lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
sometimes i feel like i don't have a
partner no
sometimes i feel like
my only friend
is the city i live in the city of angels
lonely as i am together with crowds
horrible
right when i said wow that note right
before that was just truly atrocious but
i will say honestly have you been
working on that or no because that's the
best you've ever sang it's horrible
but it's the best you've ever seen i
don't ever want to feed
god didn't take me to
[Applause]
you know how that you know what song you
know what song i was saying because it's
so good and i think i know okay
i already know what you're going to say
what am i going to say you're going to
say he sounds like he starts with an
hour
we're brothers we're brothers dude we're
brothers right yeah and we never talked
about this am i right
i don't know dude one time my friend
said dude i had a dream the other day
about a t-rex and i said oh yeah and you
want to know the weirdest thing i said
was it smaller than it than it normally
would be and he said yeah how did you
know dude sometimes you just know who
you sometimes you just know your friends
and some and you definitely know your
brother yeah that's true so speaking of
that was crazy though well i don't even
wanna feel you know what's great i sing
better now because of my [__] oh that
makes sense [__] is out so if you
thought i was good before which you did
my [__] is amazing now and i would tell
you even more i got the stents out today
i went to the doctor took them out no
it's clear as [__] yeah let me tell you
something crusty and disgusting up there
yes but also breathe better not so sure
yet but will maybe after the crust goes
over but i will tell you this much too
um
[__] i forgot what i was gonna say
hold on
okay
ah i sound different in my head oh yeah
how crazy is that dude i mean that makes
sense though right yeah i know but i
literally sound different in my head and
it always feels like i have constant
boogers let me see if i [__] well
i got my hair cut today i'm looking
really nice i need to get a gold chain
because i got to go to i got well on the
shore
because i got the girls
i got the gold watch in the gold ring
and i need to get the gold chain because
i can't have a [__] silver chain with
the gold shits because my ocd tells me
that you should not mix metals even
though fashion would beg to differ the i
took off my shirt the other day and i
was probably doing it like sexy and
suave and [__] okay and i accidentally
ripped off my chain so i don't have my
chain right now oh so it's broken it's
not on me anymore do you only have one
tattoo
no i got one there
oh and one there both of those i mean
only like tattoos in your chest
is it sex appeal or what so far
is that sex appeal or what no that's
that is not what sex appeal would be i
disagree i mean
you know sex appeal is something
different than that i disagree i beg to
differ
i don't ever want to honestly how did i
know you were going to say that i don't
know i want to get back to that that's
why i said it it's really weird that you
knew i was going to say that i know that
i don't know he's perceptive folks
wow
honestly dude it's literally gorgeous
how perceptive i am so talk about
gorgeous why do you say that word now
where's therapist talk about gorgeous
ah [__] you're [__] gorgeous i don't
know i'll do it i just come i start with
new [__] and then i run with it man do
you think people know what i'm doing
when i do that [__] your [__] god
just [__] your [__] guards well they
do know what that you're doing if they
listen to the podcast lifeline feral sex
tape yeah that's the [__] funniest
thing that there's ever been i are
[__] gorgeous ah [__] your [__]
god i want to have sex dude he copies me
he's he's gross in it though
he's when he was doing that movie when
he had his shaved head in the goatee so
he looks like wow
i didn't know there was actual good
footage of it i thought it was like
mostly hazy and great it is but like he
goes down on her
and like it's like a close-up of him
going down [__]
it's only it's not gross because it's
him it would be gross if it was somebody
else dude i know but it's it was it was
the grossest he can be
if it was him dressed as the penguin
with that [__] well that's gross would
be just demented that would never happen
oh you're [__] gorgeous
i can't get gorgeous um
so uh
he doesn't do that where's the bad
foiled again by batman
what if you were eating while having sex
what if you were [__] filed again by
batman
just foiled again by batman
[Laughter]
dude
can't even [__]
wow sound way different in my head you
don't sound different at all good so
stop saying that
so what you're going to do that's great
you're going to stop saying that
entirely
a boss
i wish i want to be a i know i'm a ceo
obviously there's no [__] nobody not
news to anybody i'm a ceo but of what uh
of of my industry of my of my of my of
me of my of my business which is me so
you know i have maybe one or two
employees but um
yeah i'm a ceo and i want to be a i want
to be a boss in a in a place though
where i go to the work every day and i
say stuff like so what you're gonna do
is zip it whoops right i wanna that'll
be so dope if you're a boss and people
talking you go whoops
like
that would be amazing everyone would
really hate you though you know that i
know but not if you were lovable and
funny about it which i would be very
funny about it might not be lovable but
i'd be very funny about it
i don't know if employees would
appreciate that
they'd appreciate my [__] christmas
bonuses to tell you that much okay well
that's entirely separate well i don't
ever wanna feel
like i did that day
why do you make it always a vibrato
thing it's not necessarily just a
vibrato it's also
i do runs what's that it's like when you
play with the note when you when you
when you're when you're playing them
with the note okay well why
i don't ever want to feel here's an
example like i did that day
i know what it is because you said it
but i want to know why you do it
it's better it
makes the song rip a little i don't like
it oh well you're in a minority but if
you're going to sing under the bridge
you got to sing it like ketus you don't
[__] sing no that's where i'm not a
[__] cover band dude i bring my own
[__] to it okay i bring i'm i'm an
artist so excuse me if you want to be mr
[__] you know
but i do i'm a crazy artist
you know okay i sing it good though at
the top of the show that's fine um so i
got the nose surgery the stents came out
feels amazing breathe breathe in breathe
out
got a machine head that's better than
rest
bad
is that that song no it's a different
song same guy though so why would you do
a different song when we were singing
this one it's called a medley but it's
not medley because it's both of us and
it's called
bush a gavin rossdale medley you know
gavin bullsh of bush
[__]
orgy you know
gameross does gay
no
i didn't even know that either it
doesn't matter though i don't see color
oh that's not color but i don't never
want it so
breathe in breathe out that's the most
90s song of all time dude love it
they're the bush is the most 90s band of
all time for sure so got a machine head
it's better than mouse all right so
provocative to call the band bush that's
like calling her ben schlong schlong
dude yeah dude
so [__] like
remember when that was when bush was
created for the [__] p word oh dude
um have you heard
are you familiar with the bench long
no you know okay yeah uh but i will say
uh
uh i can breathe better and it's amazing
and i hope it keeps going you know it's
very crusty and disgusting up there
dusted and busted but um
yeah it's good and uh i feel good and he
said the swelling will go down i gotta
go in tomorrow and he's gonna clean it
up nice dude he's gonna take the suction
in and just go
oh disgusting disgusting yeah yeah yeah
did you get the cotton out well that was
out day one oh really yeah that comes
out the next day ouch
um and then [__] ouch did that hurt
uh
no not at all i actually i actually i
heard that it was going to be so either
so awful or feel great
people have different they're like
people say it's the worst part of the
surgery is getting those cotton parts
out the [__] out of here don't believe
those people no no no the like doctors
say oh yeah and um
and then
i i literally didn't know he did it yet
oh i didn't feel it yeah which is really
weird cause i wasn't numb i was like did
you do it and he was like yep oh i was
like oh it's done
because i expected something had you
taken the uh coding or no it wasn't
because of that no yeah i took i did
take it but i mean like
i mean i'm tough too so i don't feel a
lot of stuff
um yeah so it's all good for me because
i don't feel [__] stuff because i'm
tough but uh but uh that same doctor
okay did this the thing that doctors
clinically consider this the the third
most painful thing that is like a common
medical procedure i mean obviously like
what getting shot 80 times yeah more
painful than but it's childbirth yeah
kidney stones yeah and the thing that
they had to do to me which is remove a
tonsillaric abscess
i didn't know that that's what you had
yeah tonsil [__] is just it was i had i
i still had my tonsils at the time
and uh i had an abscess growing
on my tonsils it was closing off my
throat
i [__] got sick like immediately
overnight i was luckily i was at mom and
dad's house i had to sleep there i
couldn't even get my car but i went
there for dinner felt fine by the time
dinner was over i had 103 fever and had
to sleep there what passed out woke up
at 7 am dad was like i'm not [__]
going to work i'm driving you to shawn's
because i was i had i already had the
[__] sinus surgery with him
so the infection was up there that's why
i had the surgery yeah after the surgery
it moved dude it was living it was
living it up in my head dude and it went
down to my tonsils and then it created
an abscess back there and i go in there
and i can't swallow i have 100 304 fever
sean did we get there sean clears out
his entire doctor's office other
patients makes him leave
makes dad leave
that was like i don't want to go he's
like you can't stand here i've seen
people [__] pass out from this [__]
and i was like what the [__] is going on
and he's like i was like what if i like
waited a day he's like dude if you
waited a day
i if you waited an hour you might be
dead i was like what are you talking
about he's like i gotta take this thing
out of your throat right now did he put
you under no he didn't have time he gave
me one [__] vicodin gets these
[__] horse dick sized like silver
[__] rods
and like a big [__] long mirror thing
and it just starts [__] going to work
got a machine head it's better than what
if that's what he was doing
but dude so i'm in the chair and i just
see blood going
oh my god and he's just like breathing
breathe out dude if he did that
but the dude the blood was going
i don't ever want to feel
like i did that day how amazing would it
be though if that's what he was doing
because you'd be in so much pain but
you'd still be like god he's really
[__] awesome yeah i mean that would
be the [__] but here's his foot here's
the real reason i brought up the story
though okay okay i'm batman it's because
of the toughness of me he warned me he
said before he did anything he said
matt i wish i could say something else
but this is going to hurt so bad really
and i was like do it because i was in so
much pain already yeah so i was like do
it make this stop
and as he was doing it i was thinking
as it's good he said that because it
hurts but it doesn't hurt that bad
because you were ready yeah i was so
ready so that was like the opposite of
what he did for me where he [__]
sprayed ants up my nose and i passed out
right yeah exactly all right well but
also the thing
that thing the moral of the story and
the story that's what killed george
washington oh [__] yeah dude i'm tough
he's tough he won the war and [__] first
president general
i'm tougher
i survived it
wow
wow anyway got a machine hand
so uh insecure um
all right so let's do uh
let's go let's do let's do it
let's here we go first one brent morin
what's up guys dan here from north
carolina got one for you
so
where we live we've got two wooded lots
on either side of our house
we're tucked back in the woods a little
bit cool people drive down our road in
our neighborhood and i guess think no
one lives here i'm just gonna litter
all the time super frustrating
uh
the other day i got my front door
cars driving by
as they're passing through
a bunch of papers and napkins fly out
the window it's
naturally brm
uh but what can you do go and pick up
all the [__]
one of the items though was a receipt
with her name on it oh wow from papa
john's
40 pizzas 40 days fat [__] yeah so i'll
look her up on next door of course she
lives in the new neighborhood
pause it too
and
bro this guy's like the [__] casual
liam neeson i will find you i will kill
you
i will find the papa john's you want to
i will ask for the statement and i will
find you and i will kill you
all right what do you think of that um i
don't know if you did anything rad yet
you got to wait well go ahead
yeah she lives like a quarter mile away
so i killed her my question is what's
the best thing to do here do i shame her
on next door
do i send her her receipt back in the
mail and say
change
uh do i move onto her front porch wow
that would be amazing and confront her
i don't know those all sound pretty bad
so hoping you guys have something to
chase by the cops love the show sorcerer
okay
yeah yeah by the way
oh okay yeah he knows them all but he
knows them all he's got him um i i he
said those are all bad ideas but i like
the idea of bringing it back to her
house
right but maybe he could hand deliver it
and be like you
left this at my house dressed in a suit
just to really confuse the [__] out of
her right with a rose uh yeah i would
like to give you oh you dropped this
what what yeah you dropped this right at
my house you drove by and you thought my
place was the truck yes the trash can
yeah yeah and then do a spin move
no you know what you know what he should
do
he should do it in person all you should
do all that yeah but he should take a
trash can with him yeah and he should
say
do you see me and you see this
do we look the same a magician do we
look the same yeah and then when she
says no
he could act confused and be like well
then why
did you treat us exactly the exact same
yeah wow
so [__] much work to do that but
what he should do is go over there and
ring the doorbell when she opens it take
trash and just drop it out of place yeah
i mean she'd be like sir what are you
doing and he says well exactly what you
did yeah yeah exactly what you did yeah
you threw a receipt from papa john's out
of my [__] front door so what i'm
doing is there's the same thing bye and
say and then [__]
who the [__] that's so gross dude who
throws trash out their window
dude i'm never once done oh wow really
why would you throw trash out your
window throw it away when you get out of
your car
well it's if it's super gross
and like you you don't want it to get
all over your car i understand i don't
understand okay in like an emergency
your [__] kid threw up in the car
okay talking about a little bit back it
up a little bit though you know what i
mean not not if your kid threw up like
i'm saying like if you have i don't do
this but like if i had a wet cup that i
finished and all the cup holders were
full with something
no never i would never do that yeah i
wouldn't do it i would open the window
dump the liquid out and just throw it in
the back and throw it out but then still
it would get wet in the back who gives
this [__] it dries i bet i understand it
okay but it's [__] rude and shitty it
is rude and [__] okay so he should send
it back bring it back whatever i think i
mean what he should really do if he has
the time and gives a [__] is send it
back in the mail with a note
yeah fair enough yeah i would say that's
a good move uh it is interesting how
much that works i mean it must happen to
this guy a lot actually clearly yeah
yeah so but but he said it did though he
said people treat it like it's a you
know but after he got done bragging
about that he lives on the right has
like a beautiful big estate you know
we've got acres and acres upon acres and
whatever i get it but you know yeah
uh yeah it sucks so i guess yeah that's
it mail it back to where that would be
really interesting yeah with a really
heartfelt like lick man it really sucks
yeah yeah i can't believe what you did
i'm trying to get over it me and my wife
are having a hard time
that would be great we're gonna get over
it at some point it's okay yeah it's
really hard it really it's really you
know dealing with this would be one
thing but dealing with it while she's in
bed with cancer really is hard right
right no you're just adding to our
problems right right right yeah so go
ahead yeah
all right
pause it pause it pause before it starts
okay
i love her wow
hey chris and matt um my name is
brittany and i'm from newfoundland
canada um i've been a huge fan for a
long time um i've been listening to
congratulations since 2018 and i've been
a member of the church of k
since
it started yeah like
and i'm your biggest fan man like
anyone who says otherwise is dead to me
wrong wow it's both of us but yeah um
but i'm looking for advice
because
the other day my house caught on fire
while i was in it with my cat we did get
out and no one was hurt um
saying not so casually but like
that's what happened and
um
i've had like really really great people
around me because my friends are amazing
my co-workers are amazing my family is
amazing
and they've all been helping me so much
and it's been i mean jesus like it's
been so overwhelming like the love that
i've received
um
which isn't a complaint it sounds like
i'm complaining about it but i'm not
what i'm struggling with is accepting
the help and not feeling guilty for it
like
i feel like i have to
like tell everyone like you you
shouldn't be helping me like don't help
me but that's
like insulting and i just i don't know
how to accept it
to myself that
like it's okay to accept help
um and again i know this is like such a
silly complaint to have and it's i'm so
privileged to have such wonderful people
around me it's great and i am so
grateful because i do need that
and i do feel loved but i just
don't know how to
accept that other people want to help me
yeah i was just wondering if you guys
have any tips around like accepting help
and
yeah
just accepting help and i know that you
both were raised catholic so you can
relate to that catholic guilt thing yeah
i'm pretty sure that's where a lot of
this comes from but yeah just any tips
i would really appreciate i feel like
and thank you guys so much for all the
laughs and
yeah
yeah thanks
i feel like uh my version of this is
like i did it today dude i caught myself
like i was getting my nose stuff done
and then afterwards i went to a cafe and
i sat down i ordered some food and these
two
women walked in and i just decided uh
they [__] hate me oh like that i do
that i i talk about my podcast i always
think somebody hates me when they walk
into a room or like all these people all
[__] they don't like me i'd have to
like make them like me which is so much
work and stress and like mental [__]
[__] and it's all me because half
the time honestly a lot of the times
they'll walk up to me and be like hey
man big fan or whatever the [__] yeah or
also you have no idea who you are
exactly it's so egotistical to walk in
and somebody hates me so yeah so um
so i did it i was like oh this chick
hates me and i was like
dude no they don't man why am i [__]
thinking of this and it's just like this
stuff like i mean that's a different
thing than what you're dealing with but
that's all something you're putting on
with putting on and you don't need to
like dude it makes people feel good to
help you and you'd do the same for them
and it sucks that you feel that way and
it's a weird thing to complain about but
then you're adding the double stress of
oh [__] but now i feel bad i'm even
complaining about it like dude just like
let people help you because this sounds
so [__] but like because you matter
dude like you just matter as a person
you're just a you're a person that
people love and besides that you're just
a person your [__] house caught on
fire which is the worst thing yeah you
know
like it's the worst thing so just
[__]
let them do it you owe it to yourself
and them to just let them do it
yeah i mean she's great i love her i've
known her for a while just online and
stuff um
uh and she seems sweet yeah she's great
um and that's terrible that that
happened but i think the truth is
you
think of it this way if it happened to
someone you loved
you would want so much to help the
person it happened to
and you would be touched if they let you
help them
so think of it that way you're the
people that are wanting to help you
you're ma you're making them feel good
by accepting their help i'm bad at
accepting other people's help as well
but
when i realize
accepting their help makes them feel
better i'm not doing them a favor by
getting out of their way or like not
accepting their help they're not
extending the offer because they're
secretly hoping i don't [__] take it
they want to give it to me they want to
help it makes people feel good to help
so let them and then also receive the
help so you both end up benefiting it's
a good [__] thing you like to help
people let them help you
everybody ends up benefiting and um it's
[__] great especially if you have
chick friends chick love to do that [__]
dude chicks love it chicks love it dude
one time i think it was yeah it was
kristin she was like i wish you were
because i don't remember might have been
it might have been cassie before i don't
know i think it was kristen though she
was like i no it was kristen for sure it
doesn't i totally [__] remember no
but i remember but i want to get it
right though okay
she was like i wish you were sick and i
was like what and she was like i just
like love to take care of you all day
wow and i'm just like so chick like
chicks love that [__] dude and dudes do
too if they're [__] [__] if they're
[__] mates you know what i mean so if
you have [__] made friend dudes then
great and if you have chick friends then
great they want to help you no i i
one time in the middle of the night i
got a call from someone i i really kind
of don't know not not didn't know that
well even at the time
i mean everything is taken
and she was like
i don't really know why i called you
this is not someone i was romantically
involved with at all someone i was only
kind of friends with she was like i'm in
jail i got arrested can you come pick me
up are you [__] [__] me and i was
like yeah i'll do that when the hell was
this this was years ago i mean did you
ever tell me
i don't know no maybe not you don't know
her
uh chris knows her why did you why did
she call you i don't know i think she
just thought like i would be the one
that wouldn't judge her yeah whoa dude i
wish you called me i would have done it
i would have loved a stranger you know
that sucks dude you know what give her
my number if it happens again man i
would love to show up and be cause that
you know when they say like people are
like yo last night was a movie yeah
you could say it after that that was a
it's like a [__] up independent movie
but like last night you could say like
this last yo last night was a mo it's
actually a movie i think like i think
she could actually say last night was a
play her it was a play oh yeah
yeah right right
yeah what do you want like oh i'm here
to pick up my friend yeah you don't even
barely know her yeah what do you do and
a white tank top let us sweat it out
yeah yeah yeah yeah we threw in a drunk
tank yeah really has she been drinking i
don't know the papers here say you know
a bunch of prop papers and [__] yeah
yeah it was a play but uh i don't even
really talk to her anymore
well i i got her out of jail
she's a convict so it made me feel good
it made me [__] feel good right yeah
and that's that is the point
people
like to give you know what she was in
jail for yeah
was it bad drinking and driving
drinking and driving
wow yep well
okay
so let people help you yeah let them you
matter thanks brittany
what's up man chris my name's shaq quick
question
um the illest guy in the world so my
wife and i got married in october and we
live in a town house
and when i joined boys
and when and the thing is i really don't
want to join boys to man but my my look
my face and my glasses
and also uh my my chain and the hat and
particularly the way my hair is behind
it uh i and my wife says you have to
join boys
and i'm just like god but that's not me
you know and i can't even really sing
but she's like but look did you look in
the mirror and i do every day and i get
what she's saying so my question is
should i be the fifth member of boys to
men
and perform with them always on the
second show at the mirage after the
comedian
dude they do they perform every [__]
friday saturday on the second show after
whatever comedian is there dude that's
so weird
there's nothing more voice to men than
that dude that's so weird
you've been so rude to the guy but what
yeah you look so much not about that but
now you're just talking about the mirage
you know what i mean
it started out good but now you're doing
my last video
i just married my wife and sure
but the thing is i wonder if when she
tells me to take out the trash it's like
how hard it is to say goodbye to
yesterday anyway that was bad yeah yeah
because i didn't know what song i was
singing okay anyway go ahead
every time we play music here we go or
watch a movie or something she'll call
the cops on us because oh god they say
it's too loud
oh that's hard
we wanted to be cordial so i went over
to her house
and knocked down her door
she never came to the door at any time
she never comes to the door
i've done spin moves in front of her
doorbell so she knows i'm capable of
like doing those kind of moves but
yeah
i don't know what to do at this point
she keeps calling the cops on us they
say they're gonna find us if we keep
doing it but it's like all hours of the
day it could be like 3 p.m wow and we're
playing music that's not right where did
you live like what's the date she's
calling the cops on us so
yeah
i've thought about signing her up for
scientology
and that kind of stuff just so she's
getting a bunch of mail coming to her
house just mild inconveniences yeah
i can't think of anything that's so
weird i need y'all's help yeah to get me
out of this pickle so i don't have the
cops coming to my door
banging on it every single day that's
crazy i appreciate it i'm seeing chris
in
atlanta in september can't wait me and
my brother are going to come see
and i guess we'll make friends with that
guy from a few weeks ago who's moving
here so oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah hell yeah i'll be in atlanta
chrisley.com god damn it i always we're
going to do that up front atlanta
chrislea.com it's almost sold out go to
chrisleya.com also be in washington dc
uh i want to get to your problem sir but
uh in washington dc and then also uh
dallas and then also uh wichita so
anyway next question
[Laughter]
no i i honestly think you should write
her a note what an [__] she won't
come to the yeah that's the biggest [__]
that it's like all right at least
[__] man dude it's not like he's got
a gun waving it in your face his [__]
soundtrack his music is too loud you
know what i mean like not even too loud
but right right right i mean right well
even if it is though it's like
how is that the first step dude well
yeah
and say hey can you turn it down can you
move it off the wall like there's
there's solutions here also if she's not
black if she's white just play the race
thing yeah well 100 do that yeah uh it's
all it's probably it's a white lady
thing to do to call it probably white if
she is white i i applaud the dude for
not making it about that but you know
what i mean that's that is yeah
uh that that uh
is so annoying and uh but definitely get
get crafty and get silly with it you
have to because i mean she's doing
everything legal but it's still shitty
you know so you got to get crafty with
it how is that the first i can't believe
that dude calling the [__] cops well
noise pollution's a real thing but knock
on the door dude come and knock on my
door i know i get it but also
like
she's uh like it sounds like she's like
just some woman that lives there and
she's probably [__] her dude well she's
obviously scared of she'll kill her he
should kill her no i shouldn't wipe her
out okay so it's gonna be have the
disclaimer first but uh
no but he should like right or not and
like be a human to her and be like look
um i don't know how we got off on this
foot but like can we just like have a
conversation about this instead of like
immediately going to the [__] police
yeah you should actually knock on her
door and be like ma'am before you make
the biggest mistake of our lives don't
do it baby
yes
um
digest all the cops i think you need to
like establish even though she won't
come to the door you got to figure out a
way to establish
a line of communication with her and
like represent yourself as the human
that you are and like sometimes people
just like
lash out and do the extreme thing and
then they're like that sort of that kind
of behavior crumbles under the
realization that they're doing it to
just a human being yeah yeah yeah right
yeah no i totally agree so i think maybe
if you can somehow
even though she's not coming to the door
like a [__] complete [__] yeah
like get write a note to her like even
if you have to write like several like
make it your mission to establish a line
of communication with this woman and and
i think that if you can
exhibit you're just like just what you
did with us that you're just like a
[__] human being uh i think she might
actually be reasonable i mean yeah i
mean it could be but also you are also
the brother the delia brother that
hasn't seen fear thy neighbor and that
is a [__] show that i've told you
about that people wind up dead there and
it always takes place in atlanta so i'm
just saying dude you think he's gonna
die or the other woman's gonna die
no
in the show he would die oh really well
yeah because it's always the person
that's like what's the problem oh really
yeah oh okay i'm sorry did i like
because they don't know i didn't know
what i was doing and then all of a
sudden they were on my front lawn with a
[__] ak whoa
uh yeah dude uh
but also get silly with it and get you
know do things that you can be
creatively
like
you know uh uh
uh
what do you call it like [__] her life
up in like the ways that she's [__]
yours up you know because i mean that
that could escalate though it could
escalate but all but it can if you're
like well that wasn't me right yeah yeah
true i didn't do that i'm sorry that
left the [__] but all those voices
out that's not going to stop that was
the thing though that's not going to
stop the cops
no it's not going to stop her from
calling the cops rather yeah i might not
but you might get the hint if you wink
you know what i mean it wasn't me and
then wink
no i think honestly you gotta
just show her the human that you are and
and like make her
hostility crumble
that's i hate people like that me too
that's that's like the worst [__]
[__] i feel so guilty like in hotels
when people are being so loud and like
i remember once i i called the front
desk because it was like 3 30 in the
morning and it wasn't even like a friday
or a saturday and it was so they were so
loud playing music and i felt so guilty
calling cause i was like i should just
go over there and [__] say something
but the reason why i didn't well i don't
i think the reason why i didn't is
because i didn't want them to be like oh
crystalia and then [__] that was a
whole thing but that's what i made it
about instead of being a [__] real
man and going over there i just called
security like a [__] but it was i think
sometimes yeah if for me
a reason i would call in that instance
is i if i got up and did it i wouldn't
be able to go back to sleep right right
right if i just rolled over and [__]
called the front desk i would have
[__] up too
yeah
uh yeah
oh dude yeah we'll be quiet can we take
some pictures me like this and the
pictures
just so it's so sweet please join the
party
what's up chris and matt this is aj from
auburn washington i just need some
advice from you guys uh my fiance and i
have been together for about four years
we have a toddler together he's two and
a half same age as calvin it's been real
cool to watch him grow up together
um
and i need advice on babysitting um yeah
i've been looking into alternate methods
of babysitting since we have no family
around we've probably only gone out
together three times since he's been
born yeah um and that could put a strain
on your relationship and um we're doing
relatively well considering but um
i'd like to spend more time with her and
i think it would make things a lot
better for us but she's concerned that
uh
a babysitter would do something to the
kid which is understandable
and he can't speak full sentences yet so
i get it
but she's absolutely not down with it so
i'd love to hear your guys's opinion on
this thank you
that's a good that's a good one because
i don't i don't
well also well first of all
don't you know people like don't you
know people that would do it yeah that's
the thing is go to people that you know
that might do it yeah or or i mean you
should handle this in general because
what the [__] do i know but i feel like
if there's a way to like contact
or connect with vetted yeah there are
apps that you can use that they're
vetted and [__] so that's your i think
that's your second best bet is if you
don't have somebody that you know that
like you trust also get like a nano
thing like video yeah yeah you could do
that but also i mean you never know
i mean that could
so that doesn't stop somebody from
kidnapping your kid which is that that's
what she's scared of
whatever right okay uh but yeah i'm i'm
of your wife's thought like i don't like
like kristen is like we'll just use the
babysitter that comes with the hotel
and i'm just like
no and and she's like they're all vetted
and they use them all the time and i'm
like yeah but i don't [__] know this
person yeah they're not watching my kid
in [__] room 205 yeah you know like i
just don't
i don't i don't like that at all and i
uh
just feel like
i'm lucky i have a nanny that we trust
and she she babysits most of the time
and we're near grandparents you know so
my mom and dad will watch them sometimes
but yeah man i i wouldn't use
i wouldn't use an app i wouldn't use an
app i wouldn't use
somebody that i didn't know
and trusted i just i don't think or or
if somebody i i knew a friend that had a
babysitter that they trusted i would do
that but yeah man i i i'm i'm with your
wife on that dude i i'm sorry to say
like
you nev bro that's your kid you know and
he's a little bit more trusting which
he's probably right nothing's going to
happen but still
ask i wouldn't be able to have fun on
the date a friend of yours or a friend
of your wife's
even if it's like can you just do us a
favor one night like watch the kids like
[__] they'll do it yeah true yeah
true did you ask a friend yeah i guess
they don't have friends i think they
have no friends in the area oh did they
just move or something i think he said
something oh he's like we didn't just
move we're actually losers
that's the thing is that uh we're so
boring anyway uh
ask ask uh
oh yeah that's then that's [__] tough
yeah what do you say i was gonna say ask
someone that you know with kids but they
do have they do have uh
they do have apps for that that vet the
people
and those people do not want to get sued
so
yeah i mean if i had a kid i would let
anybody [__] watch my kid you would
not i would let anyone watch my kid
anyone yeah
like just go ahead mailman yeah hey
thanks for mel one second uh i gotta run
the grocery store do you mind
yeah basically yeah yeah
yeah okay cool he just mails your kid
all right
hey delias
hey i was making this video she has a
question
i'm pretty sure you guys
uh how can normal guys get normal dates
and relationships without having like
the fastest cars the biggest houses
the biggest cup legs that were the
biggest [__] you know without turning
into an [__]
uh how do we get decent girls you know
that bright out looks you
[Music]
know died without like
mega amounts of money
magic tricks and
changing our own personalities
um
i like the way you guys put stuff
together you guys are a family unit it's
pretty tight oh yeah you have good work
i like chris's ferrari
okay well
it's solid the ferrari okay thanks for
listening guys yeah man i mean
i mean it's our podcast bro you're
listening to us dude he just died in the
middle he's like
i like chris ferrari
so
that was the third one that he liked
about us by the way yeah you know big
fan you guys are a family i love the
podcast um i like chris ferrari anyway
thanks for listening to my podcast
uh i mean dude i mean so many guys say
this kind of [__] i i i
i can't recommend a dating app because
i've never been on one i've never been
on one either
yeah
but um
the thing guys get in their head about
like
i'm not [__] rich i'm not like
[__] this and that whatever so i
gotta like put on a thing that is
the exact wrong step
you
don't go outward into another identity
that you think other people want yeah
you
i mean i could turn in and and i could
do it lean into the identity that you
already have
because it's it's it's not about like
confidence in like the swagger sense
confidence in like the [__]
the person is exuding uh comfort with
who they are that is the most attractive
thing are you waiting for someone why
are you saying that because that's what
you get i'm saying like i could do it
you don't want to put it anyway the good
advice that i'm giving uh while you're
doing that is your management device
yeah i think that uh
honestly uh my my friend once said to me
uh well actually you didn't say to me i
heard him say to another guy
uh
that was talking to a girl
uh uh
and he said
uh after the girl left he said what did
you say
to that girl
and he said
i don't remember
and then i said
to him
why did you ask him what he said to the
girl because he does that a lot and he
says because i want to know what to say
to make girls like me yes and it is not
about yes what you say yes it is about
who you are and you need to work on that
internally dude girls look everyone
wants money because it makes life much
more comfortable but what what girls
want more than money most girls is like
a good loyal dude yeah right
and if that's what you are even though
you're a paraplegic and you barely moved
in the video it's
you know you the girls will sniff that
out right
they'll sniff that out you die every
however long right but you come back to
life you pet narcoleptic fine play the
part where you passed out amazing dude
go back and play the part we passed out
please dude he's so funny
i'm making this video actually
i'm pretty sure you guys
uh how can normal guys get normal dates
and relationships without having like
the fastest cars i mean this guy doesn't
move at all
yeah because cox slid it in there don't
turn it into an [__] watch when he
dies uh i look at decent girls you know
that bright out looks you know uh it's
so weird
bright outlooks that's a good thing i
know but
died
mega amounts of money
magic tricks
all right cool look man magic tricks you
know that was the third this guy his his
[__] his lists fall apart at number
three
you know what i mean like what do you
want to eat um i have a turkey sandwich
a potato salad
car parts like
what dude like dude you can't pick three
dude the three every time you got to the
third thing yes i really love you guys
your family you guys are hilarious
chris's car
how do you get chicks without having
money a great personality
magic tricks
[Applause]
this guy can't do three things
you should stop at two
um oh [__] just be yourself i mean he's
clearly a [__] confident guy
i mean
i i'm assuming that's not working but
that's like
chalk that up to a streak dude you're
gonna be [__] fine he's handsome too
yeah he's a good looking dude uh you
could be fine
yeah just don't don't think what other
things do i need yeah yeah you have
everything that you need yeah i mean
yeah trust me right
oh man that was [__] funny that guy
what's up chris and matt i love the new
show
i wish there was more of it to binge
because it's so good
um i have a little bit of a tricky one
for you guys
so we got a new girl at work like maybe
a month ago or so
and they send out like a work email that
has a picture attached and it's kind of
like a professional type of job
and so i noticed that she was attractive
before she even started there
so then the girl starts i i work in like
a separate part of the office kind of by
myself so i don't go right into a lot of
people
so i can get a bonus very short we
haven't had any interaction we've never
been formally introduced as far as i
know she didn't even know i existed but
then i woke up one morning and i got a
follow from her on instagram at 3 30 in
the morning
so i guess my question is is that like a
sign that she may be interested or is he
just kind of like
an innocent coincidence maybe not three
years in the morning in the area and
she's just trying to make friends
i don't know i'm unsure if i should
proceed with any
what happened
well don't proceed with anything but
just know that because man these chicks
be calculated you know what i mean don't
ever pursue a workplace relationship
yeah don't do that i agree with you i
agree with you but my point is
she would have thought better oh i
shouldn't follow him at 3 30 in the
morning i'll follow him you know he's
one i want to follow everybody i work
with but i want to follow also did she
follow other people she worked with
that's what i was going to say like look
at that if you want to if you want to
know if it's a sign or not look at the
other people that you know from work
that are on instagram see if she follows
them
yeah yeah yeah i think that that's a
cool sign but don't run with it it's one
of those things that's like oh that's a
good sign but don't run with it first of
all even if she didn't work with you
don't run with it just
know that it happened and then maybe if
you see her next time say hey what's up
you know what i mean maybe do a magic
trick well no if he didn't work with her
then he could pursue her if you felt
like i know what i'm saying
not right away you look too eager dude
you got to chill a little bit i don't
believe in that no no but i'm saying no
okay it's fine you want to respond you
write do it right away who gives you
[__] no i know but i'm saying but matt
this is this is from
i guess i'm thinking about with the
workplace thing yeah oh yeah okay then
yeah i mean yeah totally yeah but yeah i
guess if it if it wasn't if she had
nothing to do with work then yeah you
could write it whenever it doesn't
matter yeah but just be careful with the
work thing yeah
i mean beyond careful yeah dude wow i
saw i'm still thinking about that guy
before him um i just uh
i just think uh it's a train wreck dude
it's a train wreck it's a train wreck if
you're trying to date a person i mean
look if she
pursues you
forget what i said yeah but like don't
pursue her
uh if she's [__] following you at 3
30 who knows she could be a [__] wild
card it might actually pursue you but
don't yeah if she's a wild card and she
does pursue you though you gotta be
extra careful because of that because if
she's gonna
throw caution in the wind and hit on
someone that she's working with
definitely don't go with it don't go for
her i think it might be safer though
especially if there's a written
correspondence preceding it oh
oh you're saying because you have proof
yeah
yeah okay unless she comes up to you and
says hey what's that of course yeah and
then he should say look yeah dm
now let's yeah you follow me because you
follow me at 3 30 the other morning yeah
write it to me on there so i have
evidence of it later
hitchhike 3 30.
yeah uh yeah careful
yeah
[__]
hey man chris this is dennis
uh i love the show love the brother
dynamics um i gotta cover this myself so
i think it's freaking hilarious
uh straight to the question how do you
guys deal with uh situations where like
your girlfriend or your wife whatever
poor should be friends with like their
co-workers
husbands
oh it's like it's kind of weird
co-workers um
that's pretty awesome your friends
organically when you meet friends
organically your husbands or their
partners whatever
you usually have like
shared interests because yeah you go
find people that are kind of like
similar to you but when you work with
someone you're kind of forced to be
friends right yeah um so
their significant others or their
husbands aren't normally the same type
of people it's a good point we hang out
with anyways um situation
came up a couple years ago
my wife had a co-worker it was like
close to halloween so like oh we should
go to the winchester mystery house so we
went it was like a double date and uh
the husband was kind of kind of a means
kind of meat head or something
and then uh trying to pick on me i was
like oh whatever dude so i started
blasting back but
after like 30 minutes of like
awkwardness
it became okay but other than that like
i just want to see how you guys deal
with that stuff i don't just suck it up
and just do it and i've been doing it
for like 13 years you know i've been
with this girl for 13 years
my wife
but
it just happens every like every other
year she's like oh let's make a new
friend
well anyways let's see what you guys
your angle on it thank you guys so much
bite that bullet dude bite that bullet
and [__] just go and just be like
yeah
[__] funny joke dude i [__] love
this guy by the way yeah he's cool uh
and not just because he's wearing my
merch uh you you
that's hilarious dude because i i guess
i never thought about the difference
between like you people always talk
about like oh you're you're significant
others sign friends significant others
and like how you don't choose their them
to be friends friends with them but you
have to like be friends with their
husbands and [__] because you're going
to see them
um
that's hard enough i'm really i'm really
lucky all of kristin's significant all
of kristin's friends significant others
they're all like
i i think all of them are like super
[__] cool and fun to be around which
is crazy bro it's crazy her friends are
awesome and their significant others are
like i lucked out like i would hang out
with them alone you know um
but i never thought about the [__]
uh
co-worker thing because you don't choose
who you work with so already it's like
not somebody that your wife would even
really choose to hang with they're just
trying to relationship build and then
their significant others that's
so in the weeds that [__] you got
stuck with a meat box you guys start
with a meat headache at a magic house
you know what i mean yeah of all the
like
you probably you probably don't even
want to go to the haunted house and like
you gotta go with this [__] dude
that's like so removed from who you are
that's hilarious yeah bro wow that's so
funny you know what now that i'm talking
about it
look at the [__] funniness of it
because that sucks dude yeah that sucks
you gotta do it you can't do it you ever
have one of those days where it's just
like oh all right like you go you're
late to [__] work or whatever and
then you get out a bird shits on your
car and you trip and then the [__]
coffee comes out and it falls on you and
then you got to go to work with like a
stain on your shirt at that point you
just chalk it up dude you're just like
ah [__] oh okay it's funny now yeah you
know oh i got to go to a haunted house
with some [__] somebody my wife
barely likes
person that they're married to that they
probably barely like i don't even know
this [__] got to go to a haunted
house with me with a meat head and
you're [__] sitting there and there's
and he's like oh you don't even [__]
bench huh
just an actual nightmare yeah he's
dressed like [__] some meathead regis
philbin or some [__] it's halloween oh
right and uh or just superman probably
yeah uh anyway yeah dude that's uh
that's really funny dude and that sucks
and but if it's once every he said once
every year or a couple of years that's
not so bad dude just swallow it and
remember look down at that sweater dude
life rips bro that's [__] funny man
wow 13 years huh that's so long holy
[__] yeah
good for him wow
what's up matt what's up chris i've got
a question for you guys today about a
gym partner of mine mustache has been
working out with this dude for two years
now he's an awesome guy i've been seeing
a lot of results and i'm making great
progress with him overall he's just the
man uh the only issue is about a year in
he started bringing around his cousin
who's an absolute [__] [__] i mean
the dude is just the most arrogant cocky
person makes fun of everyone in the gym
what they're putting up what i'm putting
up which is ironic he's five foot six is
this the guy that the other guy went
down haunted house 24
satiny right but just curious what you
guys think um
kind of ruining my gym experience don't
know if i should just go alone
or switch gyms
or uh something like that not really
opposed to either but uh yeah uh chris
has been rocking with you for a long
time man matt love you it's great to see
both you guys doing well and and being
successful so oh yeah
thanks for taking my question cheers
cool dude what a normal cool [__]
chill no pretense dude love it but the
patagonia hat he knows fashion dude i
will tell you what dude uh uh what i
would do if i'm being real i don't even
know what i would do so yeah oh i know
what i would do okay i would tell the
guy like yo bro i like working out but
like your cousin annoys the [__] oh yeah
i would definitely that's no question
yeah yeah 100 i would say yeah so so
like if he's going to be around that's
cool but like i don't want to work out
with you if he's going to be wrong
that's what i would say yeah and i would
say it and i would enjoy saying yeah me
too because i i i want you to know that
this is now oh he's he's somebody that
affects everything yeah this is your
cousin who you bring around is one of
those dudes that affects everything
right so now i'm gonna lay off dude i
wash my hands of your cousin so i'm
gonna go put up what i put up in a hefty
way and i don't need a spot dude thank
you for all the knowledge
but i ain't coming around your cousin
yeah yeah yeah and also it's good to let
him know his cousin sucks she should
know that yeah i mean you don't have to
say your cousin sucks but like to be
like yo bro that guy is not from like
calvin goes like this the other day i
was like he i was like hey buddy you
want me to help you with that and he
said no and i said what about teamwork
and he said he said timor
he said teamwork is not for me dude
that's a hundred percent your cousin is
not for me yeah take that calvin
mentality
so yeah that's uh wow hi chris and matt
um i love the love the podcast i'm
trying to be fast because i just found
out i have to do a minute long
or under um
but i have this guy friend at work um
and he has a girlfriend that's really
jealous of me oh boy and this
girlfriend's mom also works where i work
whoa and
like
since so they they all work together but
the girlfriend just quit and the guy
just became friends with me so now we're
friends but then the mom of the girl has
been like spying on us and telling her
daughter hey they're like flirting and
hanging out 24 7. i could care less like
i literally don't
care to be friends with him i'm just
friends with him hilarious like i don't
hang out like alone with him yeah and so
basically
so
she's been messaging me saying i'm shady
and to never talk to them again
she doesn't like her boyfriend having
friends at all like
she's in control of him but anyway um i
just want advice on how to
uh like do i
stop being friends with him
or do i just say [__] it and just lean
into it
you know and just say
like
i don't care what she says and just
because i don't like that she can
control his life you know
um anyway yeah that's my question uh
i love you guys bye oh sweetie there's
the two options just [__] blocker and
then do whatever you want and who cares
about this [__] that's the third
option that's cool go to hr dude tell if
you all work together and somebody's
making it uncomfortable for you you can
go [__] tell them dude yeah and go
tell them kind of like the neighbor
calling the cops okay but i mean if
she's two what's up option two is
[__]
spit
all over his [__] oh my god
don't do that 100 don't do that why not
dude you want troubles let's make waves
baby
[Music]
junk that's
lean back dude i tell you what man
that's like dude if you're gonna make my
life difficult at least i'm gonna come
dude forget it like that's so annoying
oh well you know what i'm gonna do if
you're gonna keep telling me that i'm
trouble i'm going to turn around in
front of your boyfriend and show you
what trouble is
[Music]
lean back
lean back that's her afterwards wiping
up okay okay that's so annoying dude
people are so annoying that's true that
is extremely uh particularly annoying
um
block that [__] idiot and never ever
think about her again
and [__] the mom the mom is the most
depressing [__] the husband or the mom
dude
mom is the most depressing human alive
oh really dude where's your husband at
show up at target while he's getting
shipped for the family
[Laughter]
get in there dude
why lean back
it's gangster oh okay
that's what fat joe does during lean
back you could do that
you could also block the woman
and not do that
because she's not into the guy so
sucking his dick
and [__] him a lot
wouldn't
be beneficial to her life
yeah well i'm sweating after that dude
yeah i'm sweating i just it's like just
everybody [__] relaxed dude everybody
was just so many [__] crazy you know
what you're talking about people make
everything worse dude everybody makes
everything worse
everything that they're afraid of they
make it [__] come true i know
everything that they don't want to
happen to make sure it [__] happens
this [__] idiot woman is making
everything that she's afraid of
everything bad that she doesn't want to
have happen make him make it way more
likely to happen
nothing would happen
ever if if if this [__] if they just
left it a [__] loan
but some [__] [__] and her mom
gotta [__] stir some [__] up and then
rock
yeah broke it's gonna be [__] deep
throat central if you don't calm down
stop dming man yeah dude i mean dming
saying she's shady that's that's like
the most [__] trashy i'm shady dude i
haven't done [__] this girl obviously
doesn't give a [__] i know she didn't
even give a [__] she didn't want to be
friends with the guy no she's not did
she know dude they're gonna [__] rank
it up dude yeah i'm wrong rank it up for
real bruh bro
[Music]
pump it up
oh i wish i did it with that song
instead that would have been way better
well lean back what song is that
pump it up by joe budden the only good
song that joe budden ever had and he
talks so much [__] about [__] rappers
it's ridiculous okay he's a hater but we
love him though he's got a great podcast
i'll tell you that much okay
do you guys want to do more i don't i
guess
we could be done
i'll never want to fear
thank you very much
i did that day or take me to the place i
love
[Music]
take me over that went with
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
dude
my nose hurts thanks everybody thanks
everybody we love you hold on we're not
going out yet we gotta we gotta we gotta
we gotta figure out where i'm gonna be
i'm in dallas all right well in the
meantime if you have a [__] question
like these beautiful people who called
in uh click on the link in the
description below or just go straight to
watchlifeline.com now what's gonna
happen is everyone's gonna click out of
it and they're not gonna know where i'm
gonna be and that's gonna be [__]
because you already did the [__]
thing but i will be in dallas let's rank
it up i'll be in [__] wichita let's
rank it up i'll be in atlanta let's rank
it up i'll be in [__] uh albany right
albany yeah i'll be in boston run run
run let's be a [__] uh uh lakeland
i'll be there i'll be in uh where else
let's see uh rug city you'd be in runk
city i didn't even come up the internet
isn't working yes dude washington dc
rank it up just a whole bunch of cities
chrisleya.com and uh we got the new
colorway the life rips colorway uh that
came out it's absolutely periwinkle he's
on his periwinkle [__] it's absolutely
we got [__] merch coming out we do
have merch coming out actually we have a
lifeline merch coming out and you guys
are going to like it a lot it's sick
yeah uh so thanks very much for
listening and you guys are great
[Music]